good but gaming I'm here with Sven
what's up Sven we're up in the sky for a
very specific reason that's right we're
gonna build an ac-130 for you could
spend this has been a long dream for my
minecraft dog he's always said it since
day one and today that day is here
because it's true I'm gonna show you
just a quick rundown and what the idea
is so basically we're gonna build at
Bombur with through a TNT duplicator I
know you're very interested it's cool
though I'll show how it works let me see
if I remember okay so bing bang and then
what you use is a core out of all items
a coral bubble whatever that is that's
how you make this to duplicate there's
old versions of this but this actually
works in the latest version of the
Minecraft no one cares you're like okay
cool and then you make this and put a
detector rail and then you put a
minecart and then you just have
something to push it and that will
actually let's put a sticky piston and
then watch this fun this is good this is
a good fun part it duplicates the TNT
Jesus which means we can make a lot of
bombings oh my god
that's cool right so I got the design
from Diamond dozer really really fun and
cool I can't wait to use this properly
why is it so satisfying damn it's so
fast
oh my god yes you see what I'm talking
about
alright they're blowing up are they
blowing up before okay I see I see I see
let's build it a little further down
then good thing I tested this oh oh my
bike okay well that was that design cool
[Laughter]
a lot of people just find these random
things
oh yeah the bubble coral reef that'll do
the trick like it comes up with that
stuff you know what this bill needs to
work a bubble coral reef that'll do the
trick okay I didn't build the crank this
time today
okay now it works twice is so satisfying
look at that
so basically now any time that's push
forward epic explosion in soos so what
we're going to do is we're going to put
the observer smurfer here and I guess
we'll put you there see if I can do this
properly and then this this F wallah try
it it doesn't work one tooth okay now it
worked and then eventually yes okay so
this is actually our base now we're just
gonna make more of that holdups event
Bracey hey we're just gonna repeat this
pattern I just realize it doesn't work
at all
now it's work so one two one two three
or six also while I'm at it this build
is inspired by I think PI he did a
carpet bomber as well and I thought hey
that's cool I want to make it okay see
it works yes
alright we keep going gamers I don't
know how big I want to make it though
that's the million dollar question how
big you want it Sven he's clearly very
invested this is great all right getting
hang over this doing this very fast
epically and as I said that I stopped
doing it okay I think this should be one
wing you know that's pretty cool that
looks cool oh I made a mistake what did
I do
oh alright there's a lot of building
that needs to be done and we're doing it
we're just doing it this wait for me to
place a TNT wrong and the whole thing
goes kaboom
gosh balloon okay works this is
obviously a lot of work but cement is
gonna be so happy that it's all it's all
gonna be worth it
please don't blow up
oh this is Gary this is fine he's fine
bing bang bong bing bang bong ping pong
ping pong ping ping pong pong pong
this is this already looks ridiculous
okay
all right it worked
glorious as stupid as this already is I
think I need to actually make it bigger
because the wing is so fat now it needs
to like be at least that long I think
all right it's getting there we have 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 17 the lucky number
please work it's all ass just working
alright looking good looking good
nice oh my god that was way too evil
come on surrenders like I don't know if
I want this alright the wings are done I
just need to build the front of the ship
and we should be good to go okay not bad
I think maybe does it work at all I am
no clue
I think something happened I I think so
I think it works I'm so amazed all right
what a laugh it looks so bad the
weirdest part of this whole thing is
that it somehow works every time I try
it I'm sure it's gonna fail okay let's
just you know what this is not no I
think what I need to do is I need to
build it and slime first and then figure
out the Redstone now I built the thing
just so I can test if it works to see if
it works
and he doesn't oh my god Oh
three two one please work okay I'm
really glad I thought this might be too
easy okay I think I did it
okay this should be a repeatable pattern
look for what I built like what I built
it's like it's gonna be an airplane
thank you
bye Maya okay once I get past this
hurdle it will actually be quite easy
just connecting these two spots I've
been literally hell
it works okay now we're just gonna make
these ovals God smash like on video cuz
my brain about to explode of explosion
brain image okay I wish I came up with
this pattern before I started recording
Jesus well that's my only wish in life
alright so we're nearly there aren't we
swing Hey hopefully this to pay off my
god my god I mean this is silly this is
just stupid it is so incredibly dumb
alright so the engine will go here this
should power the whole thing
should I try it damn us Carrie I'm
definitely backing up I how are Y now
backed up my house is flooding right now
and I'm building a Minecraft airplane
the irony that this country is filled
with water
alright we're backed up wish I could
back up my house but I can't okay here
we go oh I forgot it needs to move
forward a little bit does it hit it is
what the [ __ ] happened here I definitely
broke here
what happened although it didn't break I
just kept going there okay it didn't
work EPIK probably because of this thing
nope
it stopped swearing for another reason
and I see the problem already what are
you doing here huh what are you doing
they fixed it it's like you know you can
do it you just have to figure it out and
you know it's gonna pay off because it's
gonna look at dan that looks so cool
why does the wings not move oh no no oh
it's affected by that okay fan sex
it's already broken to begin with okay
so it's missing a piston right it's
missing one here two should work I broke
my mouse know what oh I forgot
come on swing yes it works it works it
works oh this is where the fun begins
it's gotta build the engine okay there
she goes
we just got to find a spot for Sven I
didn't think of that actually dang it
this could be a problem
wait what is what is this what is that
what are you not activate no no why all
right who's been the most patient dog in
the whole world that's right
you spin you did it just hang on we need
to find you a seat I don't know where
you okay can he fit in one of the
minecarts cuz that's not a bad idea I'm
gonna go here spin come on my mane come
on get in yeah that's my boy and then
maybe I can be like captain next to you
that looks so cool that looks so dope
alright this is the first time we try it
with a full engine let's see how it goes
all right now we're just waitin here we
go spin this is gonna be awesome
oh here we go yeah so happy it's working
said it's working
after so much trouble it's my computer
okay oh god Mike I think on my computer
is starting to have a little problem
let's have a look at that looks like oh
my god that's so cool no way
render distance computer about to
explosion why compute their social sake
come on it's having a bit of problem to
render all explosions are happening
explosions are definitely happening all
right all right I should stop it and see
kind of like with the damages oh they're
Sanjana all right what's the oh god it's
still dropping
is it still no let's see the damage
we've done okay all right that's cool
not bad not bad not bad at all spend
spend be like let's commit some war
crimes gosh so happy I'm so happy I've
could it's it was so much easier than I
thought if I didn't just build it wrong
here and had to make this whole
complicated thing to make it bit bare
and this bit there it would have been so
easy but I didn't think in advance and I
paid the price but what this is this oh
[Applause]
no there's a village when there's a
village right there there's a bunch of
innocent people
okay we better turn left we better turn
left then
kill them kill them Sven oh god I fell
down oh god I don't know where I am
help me oh no they're gonna poop pee in
their pants when they run guys hurry up
you have to run run no guile oh no
someone stop them guys please do
something
run oh no what a tragedy it's about to
happen very slowly it's a very slow
Bombur but it gets the job done
Oh God oh no not the town oh no with all
the villagers oh not the children
let the Shem friend Jesus
Manny's root plane spend you have to
stop oh they're trying to run but
there's no there's no point in running
from Sven's
little ship alright let's see if I can
find the engine oh my god it's still
bombing
all right let's look at the damage there
it is oh this is so sad
fifty thousand you people used to live
here now it's a ghost town my god
so then how could you how could you my
owns minecraft dark completely ruthless
hey two people lived how I'll because
they they went underneath hey lucky you
that's so cool eh you guys made it out
of life that's so cool that you guys no
witnesses
no witnesses chase s oh my god it looks
crazy oh my god nothing can stop us
we're invincible Sven
nothing's ever gonna stop us we're gonna
bomb the entire world Oh God
it was this a joke I'm so sorry
okay guys if you enjoyed this video
smash like subscribe we have a Black
Friday sale going on right now with
brand new March it's a great way to
support the channel thank you guys and
bye bye hey d'Or you are entering a new
era where you shall craft the own poop
the hour of our spells and poop grades
is coming
marzia Edgar and buttons need you
the diaper you will face but crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne booty is the game to play I'm not
supposed to have my opinion about that
but the prices
[Music]
you